we're in New York with some spectacular
snow motion which [ __ ] up over 12
million hits online
[Music]
ouch that's gonna hurt there is no happy
ending here the commuters that were
standing on the platform ended up
getting head injuries from all that hard
compacted snow so why didn't these
commuters get out of the way the Train
is a very massive object compared to the
snow when a large mass transfers its
momentum to a smaller mass the momentum
transfer means the snow travels very
quickly the snow here has fallen quite
recently which means it's still light
and fluffy it's probably 90 to 95
percent air but when the Train hits it
it compacts it squeezes out all the air
and turns it into solid chunks like
proper snowballs before then launching
them at the people waiting on the plane
even worse these high-speed snowballs
start to break up because of the air
resistance forming an unavoidable wall
of snow it looks as though people can
get out the way but let's see what it
looks like in real time
yep snow chance